who would you put as the top to blame
for the crash that we had in 2008.
direct answer to your question at the
top of the list and I'll explain in my
opinion is the Federal Reserve but I'm
going to put shared responsibility for
the financial crisis on on the parties
of the federal government on The
Regulators on the rating agencies a bid
on investors certainly on Bankers
certainly on the government sponsor
Enterprises at the Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac and definitely politicians
and it's a very shared responsibility no
no lenders are on your I said Bankers
okay lenders I'm sorry Originators yeah
and and bankers I think we all made a
mistake of varying degrees but the party
that had
the best ability to to prevent a
financial crisis and then fuel the
flange was the fed and let me tell you
what happened
in the early 2000s they helped cause the
uh the whole housing bubble because they
had they kept interest rates below the
rate of inflation for a period of time
that caused people to go naturally which
they always do to go out and buy more
homes and in that case uh uh take on
more and more debt and uh and because
um uh and that that caused these housing
prices to go too high in the short run
and I was back at that time telling the
chair of the Fed was that Alan Greenspan
at the time I was with Alan but at that
time it was kind of morphing into uh
Bernanke Bernanke yeah and as a side
point I think Ellen Greenspan I served
on the thrift advisory council with him
I think he got it I think he was a
really smart chair of the FED understood
the capital markets and all that in my
opinion Ben Bernanke was like putting uh
a scholar a scholarly somebody out of uh
uh out of Academia in charge of
something that is very dynamic just
didn't understand the Dynamics of
markets as well in my opinion of what he
what he showed up so I think the FED
helped inflate the housing market and
then when things needed to be cooled
down they started raising rates too fast
too far and then that started a downturn
and I started counseling at the time I
was again I was on a council there and
met with a quarterly I said we are
there's a problem creating here I said
I'm going to cut our lending
dramatically which as we did 74 percent
during during those four four years
leading up to that but he said no we
don't see housing is going to be a
problem at all and they they basically
Rose rates it turned out to be too much
and then did not inject liquidity to
stabilize the system
and what we should have had was a normal
downturn in housing it would have been
painful for everybody yeah housing
prices should have fallen 10 15 whatever
but instead uh they they let the capital
markets totally freeze and I think they
made a fatal mistake again in my opinion
of letting Lehman Brothers fail because
that put total panic into the entire
Financial system and uh and by the time
that that happened you said they made a
mistake letting Lehman's Brothers
Lehman's Brothers in my in my opinion
but you're also the book the guy that
wrote the book nothing is too big to
fail though shouldn't we allow those
guys to fail hi I'm saying that just
from a practical side when they let
Lehman fail in that circumstance at that
time that caused a downward spiral that
cost this country trillions of dollars
and millions of people their jobs and
cost housing prices to fall much further
not only housing but the stock market
housing prices and other things more
than they could have I'm not saying they
shouldn't have found a way to deal with
Lehman over a period of time or
something but the way it was handled put
a total shock and panic into the system
and they all reacted they in terms of
the regulators and for that matter
Congress and others and very
um uh reactive haphazard kind of ways
that I don't think served our country
very well at that time so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
thank you